estelle bonjour alors des aides
publiques maintenu un mais qui devrait
tout de même diminué et olivier une
réduction progressive des aides
publiques
c'est ce qui attend à les entreprises
des secteurs toujours fermés ou dont
l'activité est réduite en raison bien
évidemment du contexte sanitaire alors
on parle du tourisme du secteur de la
culture du sport et bien entendu de
l'événementiel bercy a donc dévoilé son
plan pour les à trois chants des trois
prochains mois
ces aides prévues à partir de juin
représente une enveloppe de 7 milliards
d'euros a précisé bruno le maire une
somme répartie entre le fonds de
solidarité
les exonérations de charge l'activité
partielle et enfin la prise en charge
des frais fixes des entreprises alors
estelle justement qu'est-ce qui change
sur ces dispositifs à partir du mois de
juin banque est bien olivier on va
commencer à part le plus coûteux face à
voir le fonds de solidarité
il est maintenu pour ces trois prochains
mois mais les conditions vont évoluer
actuellement se font ils indemnisés les
entreprises à hauteur de 20% de leur
chiffre d'affaires réalisé avant la
crise à partir de juin le front le fond
pardon prendra en charge 40% à des
pertes de chiffres d'affaires constatées
le taux sera réduit à 30 % en juillet
pour atteindre 20 % en août
et puis il disparaîtra en septembre un
seuil minimal de 10 % de perte de
chiffre d'affaires devrait être
instaurée pour avoir accès à ces
indemnisations
même si pour le moment le taux n est pas
encore arrêtée
du côté du chômage partiel à présent
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de reste à
charge pour les employeurs des secteurs
les plus affectés
il sera maintenu à 0 % en juin mais
passera à 15 % en juillet puis 25% en
août et enfin à 40% en septembre
du côté de la prise en charge par l'état
de la masse
salah salariale c'est-à-dire les
cotisations salariales actuellement les
employeurs de ces secteurs et je les
rappelle
culture sport événementiel peuvent être
exonérés à de 20% de leurs cotisations
salariales des exonérations et qui
passeront à parade à 15% à partir du 1er
juin jusqu'à la fin août voilà pour les
évolutions que vont subir c'est
différent un dispositif des aides aux
entreprises les plus impactés bruno le
maire a d'ailleurs résumé en d'une
protection massive il s'agit a
maintenant de basculer vers un
accompagnement de sortie de crise avec
aides et dispositifs de transition qui
seront donc mis en place ces trois
prochains mois
merci beaucoup estelle estelle farges en
direct devant le ministère de l'économie
et des finances à paris